33% des français l'inscrivent comme
première bonne résolution pour 2022
faire du sport plus régulièrement un
moyen efficace pour détoxifier son corps
après l'abondance des repas de fête
l'activité physique va vous aider à vous
sentir mieux que je le conseillais ça va
être des exercices qui vont être très
simple ça va commencer par des exercices
cardio donc ça va être déjà dans un
premier temps se mettre en marche si on
voit qu'on n'a pas assez de résultats a
pas assez d'intensité on va y aller
progressivement sur de la course pour
avoir l' envie d'aller plus loin dans
son entraînement ajoutez ensuite du
renforcement musculaire le traditionnel
gainage en veillant à garder une bonne
posture sans lever les fesses trop des
pompes pour les plus courageux ou encore
les célèbres squatte une flexion des
jambes très efficace pour brûler la
graisse des exercices simples et
fonctionnelle en ajoutant au fil des
semaines intensité et difficultés on va
commencer avec deux à trois fois par
semaine à l'idée c'est de prendre goût
au sport goût à l'activité physique et
dès qu'on a pris goût on peut augmenter
la fréquence en y ajoutant divers
disciplines un toujours varié ses
entraînements pour pas habitué son corps
à un type d'effort un maître mot la
progressivité quand le corps n'est pas
habitué à l'effort mieux vaut commencer
en douceur en astuces ça va être deux il
y aller progressivement c'est par
exemple sur la course on l'entend
souvent faut courir une heure 45 minutes
pour ça soit efficace moi je vais vous
conseiller de courir cinq minutes ça va
vous donner confiance en vous et par la
suite on termine sur de la marche donc
vous allez avoir une sortie en extérieur
d'une heure par exemple avec un peu de
course et la fois d'après on va
augmenter on va passer sur dix minutes
15 minutes et ainsi de suite une détox
sportive a pratiqué chez vous ou en
salle ce studio a ouvert depuis avril
dernier dans le centre ville de
versailles il propose des séances avec
les conseils d'un coach sportif qui peut
venir également à domicile
compter entre 30 et 60 euros le cours au
travail